So in order to deal with those problems,
we're going to introduce an extension to
markup decision processes called
TDD MDPs as opposed to plain old MDPs.
>> TDD MDPs.
>> TDD MDPs because it
was off the tongue.
[LAUGH]
>> What does it mean?
>> Well it means
Targeted Trajectory Distribution
>> Obviously.
>> And that actually you can see that
when you think about how we go from
an MDP to a TTDMDP.
So what we are trying to do is we want
to make explicit those things we said
before, so instead of having states,
we now have Trajectories and
that's just all partial plot sequences
that we can't have, that we can't reach,
that we can't get to, so it's the
sequence so far, it's the story so far.
I try to go back and
forth between trajectories and
sequences as opposed to stories because
this is actually more general than
the story example that we're using.
Actions are exactly the same
as they were before.
We have a model, but now because we
have trajectories instead of states,
we have a model that says well,
if I'm in a trajectory and
I take a particular action, what's
the next trajectory that I will see?
But it's still basically the same
things except that really
it elevates this notion of trajectories
to sort of to a first class citizen and
that we're reasoning
over trajectories now.
And now instead of having a simple
reward, we have a target distribution.
Now here I've made a sort of capital
T instead of a lowercase T and that's
because the lower case T here was sort
of standing for trajectories the capital
T stands for final trajectories
you know that is ends of stories.
So you don't have a distribution or
I guess because they have a probability
of zero for a partial dish but
all which we really care about
is stories that we care about.
So things that have higher probability
are stories that you might consider good
and things that have lower probability,
stories that you might consider bad or
less desirable.
Does that make sense?
>> I guess so, but why not just pick
the one that we want and just and
call that I guess the distribution where
the right story has probability of 1 and
everything else is 0
seems to make sense.
>> Right so that's a sort of strict
generalization of what we were
talking about.
This is a strict generalization of
what we're talking about before.
So this allows us to say,
some things are better than others and
it turns out by relaxing this hard
constraint that I'm trying to find, I'm
trying to maximize reward but instead
I'm trying to match a distribution.
It allows more replay ability,
allows players to do a few more things,
because now our goal is not to find
a policy that maps states to actions in
order to maximize long term reward,
it's to find a probabilistic policy.
That is a probability
distribution over actions, okay.
And what is the optimal policy?
It's the one, that if I use
this probability distribution,
would lead to be matching
the target distribution.
>> I see.
>> Right?
>> And just just so
that I'm still on board here.
The actions here are the things
that the story can do?
>> Right.
The story or the story manager or
the system can do.
>> And the uncertainty for that thing.
The uncertainty is, well,
what is the player actually going to do?
We don't know.
>> Right.
>> Okay, so
it's not the players actions
it's the story's actions
>> Right, exactly it's story actions or
system actions or manager actions or
lots of ways to sort of think about.
>> Things like we're going to make
a wolf appear right about now.
>> [SOUND] Yes exactly,
that was me doing a wolf.
>> Shoot I was really scared.
>> Or I'm going to make a key appear or
I'm going to unlock a door.
I'm going to lock a door because I
don't want you to go in this room.
>> Got it.
Right.
>> So, these are the kind of actions
that you might be able to take in
the system.
The model says well if I'm
in some trajectory and
I take one of these story actions,
what plot point will I end up in next?
Which rejectory will I see next?
That depends upon the player and so
all of your uncertainty here,
sort of probably comes from the player.
That's where our inter P comes from.
>> Okay.
>> And
I'm trying to get some stories and
some stories I want to happen
more often than others, but
this allows the player
agency sort of published.
Now there's a lot of math that I could
do here, but at the end of the day what
you might think is that, well now
that I no longer have this sort of
simple constraint of maximizing
my long term expected reward but
I have probabilities and
randomness and probabilistic policies.
This is going to be harder,
much harder to deal with.
But it turns out it's not.
This is often the case in
the sheen learning in AI.
If you relax a hard constraint and
make it a soft constraint
you make it something that's
more about probabilities and
probabilistic sort of search, you
actually get more power out of it and
you're able to solve hard problems.
So without going into the details I
can point you to a paper that you can
actually series of papers
that you can read here.
It turns out that by going from a hard
constraint to probability distributions,
you can actually solve
TDMDP in linear time.
>> The linear in what?
>> Linear in the length of a story.
>> That seems unlikely.
>> Well, I can prove it to you, but
instead I'm just going to
have to read the paper.